tout commence par une très belle
histoire d'amour
elle était plutôt grande avec des mèches
blondes qui lui tombait sur le visage
même son nom était exotiques katalin ce
cas j'adorais quand de sa large bouche
elle me souriait ou qu elle me regardait
avec ses grands yeux noisette
cette jument a grandi dans notre écurie
mon père avait fait d'elle une véritable
championne
par deux fois elle a concouru lors du
grand prix d'amérique
la plus grande course peut être de trop
au monde
le trot c'est cette discipline équestre
dans lequel le jockey est en fait un
driver et il est situé il tient son il
irait son cheval avec ses rennes et il
dirige depuis un sulky
donc il ya une sorte de chariot qui est
accroché à l'arrière
ayant été personnellement sur le dos
d'un cheval avant de savoir même marché
j'étais bon gré mal gré destinée à
reprendre l'écurie familiale à l'âge de
20 ans d'ailleurs j'avais déjà plusieurs
métiers à mon actif driver entraîneur
conducteurs de poids lourds éleveurs
parfois même maréchal ferrant quand ils
étaient nécessaires
et pourtant je rêvais d'autres mondes
je quittais donc le monde de la campagne
pour rejoindre celui de la ville et
pendant plus de vingt ans j'ai eu des
dizaines d'entreprises qui m'ont fait
confiance afin de les aider dans leur
transformation et afin de les aider à
améliorer leur fonctionnement
j'ai ainsi pu comprendre et voir à quel
point le monde du travail pouvait
bénéficier de la manière dont on traite
les chevaux dans le monde des courses
en effet la performance individuelle et
collective sont indissociables de la
réussite
malheureusement les courses de trot
bénéficie d'une image on les considère
un petit peu comme une loterie dans
lequel les numéros arrive au hasard et
on peine à voir que derrière ces numéros
il y a des chevaux qui se cache au delà
du spectacle c'est une véritable
compétition sportive pendant laquelle de
nombreux talents viennent s'affronter
vous avez très certainement déjà vu une
course à la télévision mais laissez-moi
vous emmener de l'autre côté de l'écran
imaginez-vous derrière un cheval vous
avez dans les rênes de quoi diriger ou
emporter un cheval qui fait à peu près
qui est cette fois plus puissant que
vous depuis votre sulky bien assis vous
avez un énorme gros plan sur sa croupe
la vitesse c'est plutôt importante vous
êtes aux alentours de 50 km/heure vous
avez des concurrents devant vous
derrière vous votre sulky touchent
parfois le sulky d'un compétiteur
dangereusement vous savez que si l'un
d'entre vous freine violemment c'est un
accident c'est certain mais si vous
laisser trop d'espacé alors un
compétiteur va venir s'engouffrer dans
l'espace et je peux vous assurer que
c'est vraiment impressionnant de se
faire doubler à 50 km heure par un
cheval dont la tête passe à 50 cm de la
vôtre et puis finalement vous arrivez
dans la dernière ligne droite là vous
devez faire comprendre à votre cheval
qu'il est temps de tout donner
alors avec votre travail vous allez
frapper sur le bois de votre sulky afin
de faire du bruit
vous allez relâcher les rênes pour
baisser la tension le cheval peut
s'étendre
et puis vous allez même le motiver de
votre voix et finalement vous passé le
poteau d'arrivée en fait la performance
au cours de cette de cet exercice sur
une durée de 1,5 à 3 km environ
vous savez que deux courses ne peuvent
jamais se dérouler de la même manière
votre cheval n'est jamais le même d'une
course à l'autre
l'issue n'est jamais garanti c'est la
capacité de votre cheval et votre
capacité à le diriger qui vont vous
permettre d'atteindre les meilleurs
résultats
c'est exactement cette sensation que
j'ai découvert dans le monde de
l'entreprise l'issue n'est jamais
garanti la compétence de votre équipe et
votre capacité à la diriger vont
déterminer votre capacité à réussir
en fait il n'est pas question ici de
rendement prévisible de machines mais
vraiment d'être vivant qui vont
s'affronter dans cette épreuve très
souvent j'ai constaté que dans les
entreprises on oubliait que la
performance individuelle et est une
condition sinequanone du résultat
financier et pâle inverse
il ya une trentaine d'années les un
certain nombre d'entraîneurs ont décidé
d'utiliser le dopage pour amélie est là
pour améliorer la performance de leur
cheval des étalons incapable de
reproduire des ruptures de ligaments
font partie des conséquences d'un tel
traitement conscient d'un véritable
danger pour les chevaux pour la filière
les sociétés mères ont décidé
d'impliquer des règles très strictes et
au final aujourd'hui ça - d'un cheval
sur 400 qui est considéré comme étant
dopé ce qui est plutôt excellent quand
on sait que c'est hyper restrictif tout
est interdite aspirine ou même ou même
caféine dans le monde du travail en
revanche les composantes qu'on va
prendre du café plus ou moins légales du
café ça peut être des antidépresseurs
mais ça peut être aussi de la cocaïne
vont être consommés de façon à compenser
la performance d'un individu ou voir
même arriver à donner un peu plus
d'énergie dans ces moments de dans ces
moments difficiles ça peut être la peur
du licenciement ça peut être les
entretiens d'embauché la promotion ou
les conflits qu'ils soient internes ou
externes que sais-je encore en fait on
utilise ces matières pour lutter contre
la peur et cette peur c'est un mécanisme
qui est très connu dans le monde du
cheval qui est basé sur celui de la
gestion du stress et je ne veux pas ici
vous parler du bon stress
celui qui nous permet justement d'avoir
ce petit coup de pouce
coup d'adrénaline mais le mauvais stress
celui qui dure celui qui va vous rongez
vraiment le stress et composés
d'énormément de facteurs neurologiques
et physiologie et physiologiques et
c'est cette complexité sûrement qui en
fait un système qu'on trouve très
difficile à juguler dans le monde du
travail
son application s'appelle surmenage ou
burn out
pourtant le stress n'est pas une
fatalité
en aménageant correctement les façons de
travailler il est possible de le réduire
voire même de le supprimer
malgré une nervosité incontrôlable notre
jument katalin ce cas est arrivé à se
hisser parmi les 20 meilleurs chevaux de
sa génération au niveau mondial quand
pourtant qu'entre mon père s'asseyait
sur le sulky c'était une catastrophe la
jument était surexcité elle avait elle
était persuadée que ça y est c'était le
moment de courir alors on devait
remplacer mon père par quelqu'un d'autre
qui permettait de remettre la jument
confiance est là permettent de faire un
entraînement complètement efficaces la
confiance c'est un élément qui est
extrêmement positif dans l'entreprise et
qui permet justement de combler ces
problèmes liés au stress et avec un
cheval c'est très facile à faire vous il
vous suffit de vous comporter de la
bonne manière
elle s'habitue à votre voix elle sait
que votre comportement apporte quelque
chose de positif donc elle peut
concentrer son énergie à la performance
et non la concentrer à la gestion de sa
peur et son anxiété
en fait le stress et la confiance à un
plutôt la confiance à un énorme avantage
dans l'entreprise c'est qu'elle ne coûte
pas très cher à mettre en oeuvre mais
l'autre inconvénient c'est qu'en fait
son retour sur investissement est très
difficile à calculer et malheureusement
les techniques de management de l'ère
industrielle
sont venues s'appliquer dans nos
techniques de management et dans notre
univers de travailleurs du savoir ce
qu'il fait que on va poser un stress
permanent et on pense qu'on est capable
de gérer des gens de la même manière
qu'on est capable de gérer des machines
ce qui est une aberration puisque on
sait que le stress favorise la facultés
motrices au détriment de l'activité du
cerveau donc on va déployer des
structures dans lesquelles on va mettre
un stress permanent et on va imposer
d'avoir de la créativité
on demande de l'innovation de
l'implication de la part des employés et
puis on va déployer des centaines de
procédures
on va mettre un contrôle permanent et
entretenir une espèce de culture de la
peur pour changer un petit peu cet
environnement il est nécessaire de se
rendre compte qu'on peut aménager son
environnement
mais pour cela on a besoin de prendre un
petit peu de recul et de changer de
paradigme souvent de prendre un peu de
survol je vais terminer par un dernier
exemple le monde des courses de trot est
une discipline assez particulière à
l'époque
enfin il ya assez longtemps puisque vous
voyez en noir et blanc les gens
montaient avec les jambes très longue
dans une posture assez dur voire viril
et j'ai eu la chance personnellement de
pouvoir apprendre à monter avec un
cavalier un jockey qui s'appelle yves
dreux ce père sept personnes montaient
ce qu'on appelle la monte en avant c'est
à dire qu'il déplaçait le poids au
dessus du gard aude son cheval ce qui
soulageait le dos des années après luis
filipe machel a vait un cheval qui
souffrait des reins afin de soulager ce
cheval il adopte à cette note en avant
mais il allait encore plus loin en
relevant les étriers grâce à cette
posture le cheval n'avait plus de
problèmes de reins ça a été une
révolution au même titre que fosbury
lorsqu'il adopte à sa technique et
l'imposa dans le monde du saut en
hauteur
au début lorsque philippe adopté cette
technique c'était vraiment tout ça
faisait sourire tout le monde
voir on se moquait et puis il commence à
gagner des courses à gagner des courses
à gagner des courses
quinze ans après lui tout le monde a
adopté cette technique
combien de burnout de problèmes et de
dépression et d'incohérences avant qu'un
une telle révolution on arrive dans nos
entreprises
merci